zieht man einfach komplett blond etwas
glaubt jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen
fetten krassen immer heftigen video und
zwar wollte ich mal schnell meine haare
zeigen ich weiß nicht ob ihr das seht
meine haare die waren ja mal blond und
ich habe mich eigentlich rein gewinnen
und ich finde es blond besser und wenn
dir das hier seht der anders ist halt
komplett wieder so normal und ich hab
hier noch ein bisschen land und ich habe
mir gedacht meine haare müssen nicht nur
oben neu blondiert werden sondern sie
werden komplett neu blondiert und dann
sehe ich einfach aus wie ein ja dann
sehe ich halt aus wie ein wie ein
das ist ein blond auf dem kopf eine
blondine wenn sich halt aus wie eine
blondine und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht meine freundin dieses
leidenschaftliche frisörin und kann
wirklich sehr beraten beim
haareschneiden haare stylen und die hat
da ein tolles gemischt zusammengerührt
womit man einfach mal ganz easy locker
weg die haare färben kann das hier ist
ja sieht so aus wir haben es schon
fertig gemischt das wird jetzt per kam
wo ist der kampf in meiner haare
gefremdelt und mussten nach einem schon
einwirken und dann sind meine haare über
ein blog ist ok dass wir wollen ganz
lang gelagert hat man warte mal so wie
alle folien und gleich zu übernehmen
musste line 8 über meinen kopf damit das
so heiß wird
hast du keine
einfach über meinen kopf zu machen
kann man herrlich durchkämmen ach das
ist schön kalt
ich bin eigentlich ziemlich angeschlagen
und krank aber ich werde trotzdem meine
haare bei 50.000 likes nähe war immer
das ist das zu wenig bei doch wir sagen
bei 50.000 likes mache ich mir wieder
dreadlocks nein färbt ja dann ein lila
und danach verwies streitig die ab und
macht dann meine haare gelb ich hab
geträumt auf die bank du musst aber auch
die seiten durch ja weil ich doch gerade
gut
[Musik]
was macht dir was du drauf so leute
jetzt müsst ihr eine halbe stunde warten
und wir warten einfach jetzt mal eine
halbe stunde also leute bis gleich 2000
jahre später leute ich weiß sehr gut aus
wie ein ritter es ist jetzt ungefähr um
meine freunde ist gerade doch einkauft
weil wir müssen gleich noch weg aber ich
muss das jetzt auf jeden fall abwaschen
deswegen würde ich sagen
machen wir das doch einfach mein bart
ich nehme jetzt hier diese lampe mit
ich bin einfach so gespannt kurzer witz
doch bevor es losgeht wie nennt man
einen ritter ohne helm ganz einfach
wilhelm
[Musik]
alter krass
schippmann einfach komplett blond
[Musik]
arbeite ich weiß gar nicht was ich dazu
sagen soll ich meine die singen jetzt
halt überall blaue boll blond everything
that very nice xing nicht schreibt auf
jeden fall meinen die kommentare wie
findet ihr das auf einer skala von 1 bis
10 oder so und was ich noch sagen wollte
ja das war spontan was heißt spontane
idee als ich habe das eigentlich schon
länger im kopf aber ich habe jetzt
einfach in die tat umgesetzt in diesem
video war ein kleiner fehler versteckt
der eigentlich das ganze video ausmacht
oder das video so darstellen wie es
jetzt dasteht wenn das jetzt deutsch war
keine ahnung ansonsten hoffe ich
akzeptiert nicht so mit meiner neuen
haarfarbe also ich bin eigentlich sehr
zufrieden
keine ahnung wie ich das so style in
zukunft das ist erst mal so gemacht also
ein bisschen zur seite keine ahnung und
ja mal sehen was damit passiert also als
würde ich sagen ich hoffe dieses video
hat euch gefallen ist einfach anderen
nach oben da wenn ich es cool findet
dann sehe ich dass ihr anhand der
bewertung ohne check in ab instagram
instagram hatschek instagram ab da heißt
sich alex wie alexa v und wir sehen uns
morgen 19 uhr neues video würde ich
sagen
haut rein und ja jetzt bin ich gespannt
auf eure aktie und hat ein